tropical storm watches have been posted
for southern Florida in portions of the
Bahamas this morning as AA strengthens
and pushes closer to the Cayman Islands
ita's torrential downpours triggered
mudslides in Guatemala killing at least
a 100 people officials fear that number
will go higher with 150 people still
unaccounted for meteorologist Jeff
berelli is tracking the storm this
morning Jeff good morning to
you good morning Jeff and I have to say
what a beautiful set you have there
really is nice it looks great uh folks
let's talk about the storm it is
November and you know typically the
season will be winding down but once
again we're talking about a possible us
landfall we've had 28 storms that ties
the record from 2005 we're likely to
break it because we have weeks left
still a tropical depression but Ada will
become a tropical storm later today
we're expecting landfall in extreme
South Florida that will happen Sunday
night into Monday and then the storm
moves into the Gulf and believe it or
not the chance of another landfall in
the Eastern Gulf the big story the rain
and boatloads of it and the winds will
get Gusty on Sunday and Sunday night I
do think we'll see some wind gust over
60 maybe up to 75 mph in South Florida
up to a foot of rain it's been one of
the wetest years in Miami so far that
we've ever seen we're going to add
another foot in some places and that's
going to be the big story watch out for
isolated tornadoes as well and across
the rest of the nation it is a tale of
contrast in the East over 200 record
highs possible over the next several
days Chicago near 70 Minneapolis near 70
New York near 70 but in the west it is
cold it is record cold and a blizzard in
Montana the bottom line it's everything
in the kitchen sink in the weather right
now contrast all around Jeff it's
looking pretty good where you are too
gorgeous kind of nice it's beautiful out
here 70 de G woo love that